it's kind of a serious topic but we can
get through it the coronavirus
you know the pandemic it has upended so
many
of our lives and led to a surge in
divorces across the u.s so
let's get into it y'all specifically how
can women rebuild and recover
their lives after divorce and joining me
to talk all about this
is women's empowerment life coach
tiffany fambro
tiffany thank you so much for being here
how are you
i'm doing well thank you for having
monica absolutely okay folks in all
transparency
tiffany is my baby sister
she's an expert in this field and she
herself
is a divorcee that's why i wanted her
here she's been doing this
for over 20 years she's the smart smarty
pants in the family she has the
bachelors and the
masters and working on something else i
don't know anyway
tiffany thank you so much for being here
let's get right into it how has the uh
covet 19 pandemic affected marriages and
families
across the u.s i know you keep up with
all those numbers and statistics
gosh monica it has affected marriages
and families on several different levels
let's first talk about illness when the
pandemic first came out we did not know
what was going to happen it was still a
mystery we didn't even know how it was
being spread
so so many families dealt with illness
they felt dealt with death
death and so it heightened the
psychological fear of the
unknown that was the first way then we
talked about
quarantine i mean overnight people were
literally having to work from home
children were having to be taken out of
school it was quickly a disruption
in the family routine so this is
something that everyone
immediately had to get accustomed to
then monica when you talk about work
most of the time before cover 19 one
third of our lives 90 000 hours of the
human experience
was spent at work so now you're at home
with your family
yes that you love but you're at home
dealing with this
issue of the fear of the routine
disruption yeah
so what a marriage that was in struggle
it was just going to get worse yeah
now of course you know everybody's
talking about this is in all the news
cycles on all social media bill and
melinda gates
uh their divorce shocked the world i
mean i was like floored but financially
speaking you know they got access to any
and everything they want on the planet
what about the rest of us you know the
emotional stress
what are some of the emotional
challenges that couples women in
particular cope with
that are going through divorce
absolutely and monica you know i went
through this myself a lot of women deal
with guilt
shame and grief guilt even if they
wanted the divorce because they feel
like they're the reason that the family
is being pulled apart especially if you
have
children involved then you talk about
shame this feeling of failure
you know in our society we kind of have
this idealism of marriage this perfect
happy life
and so when your marriage ends in a
divorce you feel like you failed
yourself
your family and even your society then
you talk about
grief even in the worst of marriages
this is the person you've been with for
years and years and years
and many times this might be your best
friend or your best confidant
but you find by the end of it at the end
of the day it's still a loss
you're gonna go through the steps of
grief yeah
all right tiff i don't have a lot of
time left but for women that are
starting all over after divorce what are
some of the first steps
that should be taken toward living a
happier life and what are some of the
pitfalls they should avoid
fully well monica i tell women to use
the heal her method
heal envision and reinvent heal yourself
forgive yourself so you can move forward
envision the new life that you want to
have and then start getting crystal
clear about reinventing
and taking control of this new identity
you want to have moving forward
so it's the her method heal envision and
reinvent
very cool okay so after divorce give us
some examples of how women can reinvent
themselves
so that they can live those amazing
lives that you're living there
in a south carolina sister absolutely
well it's all about habit change monica
and the first thing i tell women
create clear boundaries say no and mean
it no is a complete sentence
and you're good at that by the way
telling us no but go ahead go ahead
absolutely you don't have those
non-negotiable hours
in your calendar where you have to say
no so you can give to yourself
secondly create a powerful morning
routine wake up giving gratitude
journaling how you want your day to
start
being thankful and third do activities
where you can really reflect on your own
value and your worth
and know how much you're giving back to
the world all right tiff thank you so
much we appreciate it and i appreciate
you sharing
your personal business i know we've
never really talked about it sitting
down but you were kind enough to
pull all of us together when you had
announced your divorce so i love you and
thank you so much for sharing
uh all of that information and folks
just so you know i know my sister looks
very young
she's been doing this for 20 years she's
also a fitness expert she competes in
bodybuilding
so that's why she looks really young
she's not as young as she looks just
putting it out there
all right tim thank you so much i
appreciate it i'll talk to you later
sister
all right hey folks and don't forget to
catch my moj show facebook live
tonight at seven and throughout the week
at 7 00 p.m
we're talking about the las vegas
culture and news you can use
sherry i had to put that out there
because ever since she was a
child everybody thinks she gets carted
everywhere she goes
and i'm like you got to think about them
yeah it's like she's been in business
for 20 years
she's older well you know you know how
his women are we're looking at her going
she's so young what does she know
exactly
no great advice and really the guilt
thing is so real for so many of us yeah
and when you recover you know we're
products of a divorce uh divorced parent
so
we know the other side of it as well you
got the women you got the family and
then you have the kids
you know so that's a whole different
type of bet yeah great advice there
appreciate it monica all right